[Musique]
Nicolas dupontignant bonjour bonjour
nous vous recevons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne Youtube qui s'appelle seriew on
vous reçoit dans
votre démarche de présidentiale
qu'est-ce que vous pouvez nous dire
là-dessus c'est un immense défi vouloir
sauver son pays sauvé contre
quoi
contre la décadence le déclin la
perte de son essence même de ce qu'on
est sa
liberté mon mon
idéal qu'est-ce qui a fait perdre ça la
France en partie c'est dirigeant c'est
trahisons et puis un assoupissement
aussi collectif donc mon boulot c'est de
réveiller les Français et de leur
dire attention l'histoire ne repasse pas
les plats
éternellement 40 ans
de 40 ans de légèreté de
désinvolture ça se paye cher et j'ai pas
envie que mes enfants soient les
habitants d'un pays de seconde zone ça
ça se paye comment et c'est quoi un pays
de seconde zone c'est un pays pays qui
est plus
libre c'est un pays qui est pas fort
c'est un pays qui est pas juste la
France pour moi elle doit être libre
forte et juste c'est c'est ça la France
c'est la France que j'aime en tout
cas moi mon mon ambition si on peut dire
c'est c'est une belle ambition c'est de
rendre au français la France qu'ils
aiment mais c'est une ambition démesurée
tellement la tâche est immense mais
c'est pas un homme seul qui peut le
faire d'ailleurs je ne suis que le
catalyseur et vous comptez faire quoi
pour tout ça bah d'abord faut convaincre
les Français de vous faire
confiance c'est mal barré non vous avez
fait combien au dernier score des
présidentiel ah en 2012 ben c'était pas
si mauvais 2 % un peu moins de 2 %
j'étais à 0 % dans les sondages personne
me connaissait et il y a quand même eu
plus de 600000 personnes qui ont été
mettre le bulletin dans l'urne d'un type
qui était inconnu et à qui on prédisait
l'échec
absolu ça m'a
pas découragé on a construit un
mouvement politique aux européennes on a
fait 4 % aux régional j'ai fait 6 et
demi en Île de France là les sondages
nous donnent entre 2 et 8 les sondages
il valent
rien et la seule question qui que je me
pose c'est est-ce que tu fais toi tout
ce que tu dois faire pour ton pays j'ai
le privilège parce que je considère que
c'est un privilège
d'être député de la nation de depuis un
certain temps c'est quoi un certain
temps depuis
97 j'ai le privilège d'être maèire d'une
ville réélue à 80 % dans une ville de
banlieu à trois reprises ça veut dire
que les gens me font confiance
localement à partir moment je suis
dépositaire d'une petite part de
confiance très modeste mais
réelle et que j'ai une certaine idée de
mon pays bah mon devoir c'est de faire
tout ce que je peux pour faire triompher
mes convictions mon idéal et et et
l'idéal de ceux qui m'accompagnent aussi
parce que je me sens poussé par ceux qui
m'accompagnent qu'est-ce qui va
qu'est-ce qui va vous obliger à tenir
vos promesses
rien on peut pas faire quelque chose
pour vous obliger à tenir V vos
promesses vous savez souvent je dis aux
gens qu'est-ce que vous risquez ça me
fait penser à ce que souvent les gens
disent est-ce que vous êtes honnête je
veux dire on est on est honnête o on
l'est pas on respecte ses promesses on
les respecte
pas la seule chose que je dit aux gens
je peux pas vous promettre parce que
d'abord vous ne croiriez pas ce que je
vous demande c'est de regarder mon passé
pour comprendre mon futur vous avez un
casier judiciaire c'est-à-dire vierge
euh c'est-à-dire euh regardez dans
comment j'ai gouverné au moins dans ma
ville et regarder comment j'ai agi dans
ma vie politique j'ai plein de défauts
sans doute mais quand j'ai pas été
d'accord j'ai dit bye bye j'ai quitté
l'UMP quand Sarkozi gagnait
parce que il m'a dit qu'elle allait
violer la parole du peuple il vous l'a
dit comment très simplement il m'a dit
ton Europe m'emmerde pas avec ton Europe
je vais faire un traité qui va on dira
que c'est la différent de la
Constitution puis ça sera pareil c'est
pas je dis c'est pas référendum tu le
feras adopter c'était en 2007
me dit B non par le Parlement on va pas
consulter les Français bon et j'ai dit
bon bye bye je m'en vais il m'a dit tu
te suicides politiquement je lu dis oui
peut-être mais je peux pas accepté de
participer à un gouvernement qui va
faire voter ce que le peuple a rejeté et
je pense que la crise de
confiance qui traverse toute la société
française politique et peut-être
mondiale même oui aussi il y a beaucoup
d'autres choses mais est lié à ce mépris
du peuple à cette fausse démocratie qui
s'apparente de plus en plus à une
dictature et j'ai donc j'eneviens aux
promesses je peux pas dire aux gens je
vais faire tout ce que je vous promets
de faire vous êtes pas obligé de me
croire je ferai tout ce que je peux mais
regardez ce que j'ai fait dans mon passé
j'ai toujours dit stop quand j'estimais
que trop c'était trop et j'ai jamais été
à la
soupe j'ai redressé une ville de banlieu
j'ai fait ce que j'avais dit que je
ferais je suis pas parfait mais j'essaie
de l'être et puis voilà et et puis après
j'ai envie de dire aux Français arrêtez
de dire tous pourri tous les mêmes parce
que ce faisant vous laissez le champ
libre au vrai pourri bon si vous passez
c'est pas le premier tour vous allez
appelé à voter quoi pour le deuxième
tour je fais tout pour être au second
tour d'accord si vous vous je serai au
second tour d'accord et si on y je ne
refuse de me mettre dans cette
possibilité parce que si je me mets dans
cette possibilité vous avez lu Sunzu
vous c'est une certitude c'est fin vous
avez lu vous avez lu Sunzu j'ai pas lu
Sunzu j'en ai entendu parler ouisement
une évidence mais je l'ai pas lu tout
moins je l'ai lu j'avais lu des trucs il
y a bien longtemps quand Arthur
schopenhower vous l'avez lu j'ai lu des
choses de chapanoware mais il y a bien
longtemps quand on était étudiant et
qu'on lisait beaucoup vous étiez
étudiant où oh j'étais étudiant euh euh
bah quand j'ai fait science pot ouais
hélas hélas oh mais non c'était pas une
école il y a beaucoup de cons et il y a
beaucoup une pensée unique surtout
maintenant mais moi j'ai beaucoup appris
j'ai beaucoup lu et puis voilà et et
puis on n pas obligé de faire des écoles
pour lire c'est pas faux je vais vous
passer un petit extrait de 2 minutes
d'une de vos interviews de 2015 qui
parle d'une blague et ça c'est une
blague en fait qui n'est connu que par
des gens qui font du renseignement
économique ou de l'analyse et je vais
vous demander la première question où
est-ce que vous avez entendu cette
blague là pour la première fois est-ce
que vous l'avez pas un petit peu mélangé
avec votre propre passé ou votre propre
interprétation et ensuite je vous
donnerai la vraie blague c'est une
blague qui se passe dans la jungle alors
vous la connaissez peut-être ah oui vous
pouvez nous la redire alors c'est
l'histoire du japonais du chinois ouais
ouais alors je vous écoute oh je m'en
souviens plus détail mais enfin c'est
c'est l'esprit non mais c'est l'esprit
qui est marrant c'est je sais pas si
c'est l'esprit qui est marrant mais
c'est si si parce qu'elle est très
simple alors je vous écoute c'est c'est
ce qui compte c'est pas de courir plus
vite que le lion c'est de courir plus
vite que ceux qui va bouffer allez on va
se la repasser c'est parce que là je
crois pas que j'avais très bien dit
d'ailleurs si si si si si si bon à la
base c'est pas du tout avec un lion mais
c'est avec un ours ah c'est je savais
pas et alors où est-ce que vous avez
entendu cette blague là allez je vous la
repasse pour le fun venir et je vous
rappelle l'histoire dans la jungle qui
est tout con mais qui est
marrante il y a un Japonais un Américain
un chinois un
Français toutes les nationalités et ils
sont perdus dans la jungle et ils voi un
liyon loin et il voit l'un nationalité
parce qu'après on va dire que c'est du
racisme ou de qui met des tennis qui met
ses basketsire GAE politiquement correct
qui met ses baskets et il y a les trois
autres qui le regardent et qui dit
pourquoi tu mets des baskets parce que
de toute façon on va être mangé bah il
dit non la vraie question c'est celui
qui va courir le plus vite voilà parce
qu'il va vous manger vous ben c'est ça
les c pas bien mon histoire alors on l'
refait alors elle est bien elle est pas
bien bah elle est bien elle est simple B
alors est clair est-ce que vous pouvez
c'est la mondialisation où est-ce que
vous avez entendu cette blague là j'en
sais
rien vous vous rappelez pas les
personnes qui vous l' Racon vous savez
un homme politique voit tellement de
monde entend tellement de choses que
parfois ça se perd dans le cerveau alors
pourquoi c'est ça d'ailleurs que j'ai
peut-être pas dite parfaitement alors à
la base c'est un ours on est tous autour
du feu on est bien on au chaud et puis a
un ours qui arrive et il y en a un qui
commence à se préparer il y a son copain
qui lui dit mais pourquoi tu te prépares
il dit l'important c'est pas de courir
vite c'est de courir plus vite que
l'ours mais surtout plus vite que le
dernier oui est-ce que vous pensez que
la France est le
dernier et est-ce que nos petits copains
autour du feu nous font des croch-pattes
je pense que la France est bien sûr l'un
des derniers grands pays entre
guillemets
inconscient de la guerre économique
mondiale de la guerre scientifique de la
hiérarchie qui est en train de se mettre
en œuvre des nations et si on ne veut
pas que notre pays soit un pays de
serveur de parc d'attraction une sorte
de grands eau touristique une sorte de
Venise de parc d'attraction au 21e
siècle de riches chinois au coréen
américain ben je pense qu'on a intérêt à
mettre vite les baskets et àoh voilà
est-ce qu'on a peut-être pas ce qui me
stupéfie si vous voulez je suis très
surpris de cette espèce de
naïveté pourtant je suis pas un
complotiste je suis pas un parano encore
que pour être homme politique faut être
un peu parano mais je je je ne pense pas
vivre dans le délire complotiste mais je
suis
stupéfait de la
crédulité de nos dirigeants ou alors de
leur corruption ou de leur forfiture bah
ça serait la conséquence de leur
corruption tout à fait
et souvent on croit qu'ils sont
corrompus mais on sous-estime leurs
bêtises et
ou leur légèreté et en vérité quand on
connaît un peu l'histoire de France
c'est fréquent euh pourquoi on n' pas
expulsé la délégation américaine quand
on a appris que nos dirigeants nos trois
derniers présidents étaient écoutés par
la NSA par faiblesse parce qu'ils sont
faibles vous auriez expulsé la
délégation américaine j'aurais pris des
mesures immédiates comme j'aurais donné
l'asile peut-être à à Sange ou à SN
pourquoi peut-être non peut-être par
rapport à la situation d'accord est-ce
que maintenant si vous ah je le donnerai
très clairement parce que la France
c'est la France et et la France c'est
une
idée si la France n'est pas une idée ça
devient un corps mort hein et ça veut
pas dire que c'est qu'une idée attention
il faut un mélange pourquoi je suis
golien plus que
goliste c'est parce que je crois que
c'est C cet alliage
de la culture et de la des valeurs mais
aussi de l'esprit de réalité comment
comment c'est cette culture et ses
valeurs vous inquiétez pas comment vous
voyez parce j'ai pas l'habitude d'avoir
des non je plaisante
le interiew comment vous
voyez cette culture ces réalités ses
valeurs face à la réalité de terrain
d'une géopolitique et d'une ceinture
méditerranéenne complètement déboussolée
secouée avec des millions de migrants en
marche est-ce que vous pensez que les
valeurs de france terre d'accueil vont
pouvoir résister un afflux massif ah non
mais attendez quand je parle de
valeur je parlais pas de ça précisément
mais on parle de ça là mais là oui mais
je sais de quoi vous parlez je vais vous
dire je dis toujours je l'ai dit à
plusieurs interviews si j'étais
président de la République là première
chose que j'installerai dans mon bureau
c'est une carte d'Afrique et la carte du
Maghreb et là aussi je suis stupéfait de
la
myopie ou de
l'inconscience le premier défi
géopolitique c'est le doublement de la
population africaine dans les 30 ans qui
viennent il y a jamais eu un choc
démographique dans l'histoire des hommes
aussi fort en aussi peu de temps si vous
regardez
et quand on connaît la situation de
l'Afrique de la Méditerranée le problème
de l'Europe il y a pas besoin de s'app
Einstein pour comendre que une zone de
haute pression une zone de basse
pression ça fait un orage et et là c'est
la brasse coulée on se demande
d'ailleurs ce qu'il se disent dans les
sommets européens à la
con c'est incroyable
incroyable donc oui si j'étais en tout
cas président de la République je
feraiis immédiatement des réunions
d'urgence avec obligatoirement aussi les
autres chefs d'État je verrai ceux sur
qui on peut compter je mettrai en place
immédiatement des dispositifs pour pour
prévenir si tant que ce soit encore
possible une invasion migratoire je pèse
le terme et je ne porte pas de jugement
de valeur mais qui simerait le chaos à
la fois dans les pays de départ et dans
les pays d'arrivée et les pays de
transit et dans les pays de transite en
parlons pas
mais ce qui me qui est impressionnant
mais en fait quand on regarde vous savez
quand j'étais étudiant je comprenais pas
quand je lisais les livres sur l'entre
de guerre le réarmement allemand la
renaniie et cetera euh je ne comprenais
pas comment la classe politique de
l'époque avait pu se laisser
euh bluffer et je comprenais même pas
l'aventure gaulienne ce pauvre général
qui disait des vérité sur les divisions
mécaniques personne
nécoutait il y avait quelque chose que
je ne comprenais pas et après 10 ans
dans les cercles du pouvoir à la frange
parce que je suis pas dedans mais je les
vois quand même fonctionner j'ai trou
j'ai tout compris il y a tout
aujourd'hui toute personne censée qui
sait lire des livres il des jours nous
regarder la télévision regarde les
choses voit la tragédie grec est en
train de se mettre en place on a tout et
pour autant c'est comme une tragédie
grec on a l'impression d'un enchaînement
d'événements avec des dirigeances
balloté spectateurs et moi mon
engagement politique ma raison d'être
c'est ça c'est de dire
mais il faut faire quelque choseoi et
vous allez faire quoi alors et bien je
bâtis un projet politique pour réveiller
les Français et leur dire
euh il est temps de changer de politique
il est temps de reprendre en main le
navire mais sur les flux migratoires
vous allez ah sur les flux migratoires
il y a plusieurs politique à mettre il y
a pas une politique sur le film
migratoire pour moi il y a y a quatre
grands axes majeurs le premier c'est de
remettre un contrôle national à nos
frontières ça fermera pas tout mais ça
filtrera le deè
c'est de n'accepter les traitements de
demande d'asile que si les gens restent
dans des centres de rétention aux
frontières sinon vous avez déjà visité
un centre de rétention administrative
oui j'ai vu
à troisièm vous AZ fait Mayot non j'ai
pas été je dois y aller bientôt quand
j'étais la Réunion j'ai pas pu y
aller
troisièmement il faut utiliser les
forces militaires qu'on a à quoi servent
les crédits qu'on a pour détruire les
barques de passeur on va pas me dire que
on n pas 30 milliards de budget
militaire par an
euh et on n' pas l'Allemagne l'Italie
l'Espagne la France pour être incapable
de voir les 200 passeurs qui exploitent
la misère humaine et qui assassinent les
gens au milieu de la Méditerranée bon et
la Turquie là-dedans on va parler de la
Turquie et 4èe point un plan de
codéveloppement africain qui est vital
qui est pas facile parce que une fois
qu'on a dit ça faut le mettre en œuvre
mais quand même quand la Banque Centrale
Européenne donne 1000 milliards d'euros
au banques 80 milliards d'euros par mois
en refinancement on va pas me dire qu'on
n pas
foutu de prendre une partie pour faire
des prêts à long terme pour développer
ce continent pour éviter la
désertification du Sahel règle du libre
échange recréer un marché africain des d
ré alimentair enfin bon il y a plein de
choses à faire ce serait la Banque
centrale européenne qui prêterait
directement aux africains ou à des
entrepreneurs français on verra je
préférais que ça passe par la France
mais ce que je veux
dire moi je suis j'ai pas de la réponse
à tout je suis pas Merl enchanteur mais
ce que je sais c'est qu'il y a des
choses élémentaires qui peuvent être
faites euh c'està direire on prend la
barre du navire et on pivote ça veut pas
dire qu'on va y arriver qu'on va tout
faire bien mais il y a à faire et puis
vis-à-vis de la
Turquie arrêter la soumission on me dit
on peut rien faire vis la Turquie si on
a des accords de libre échange et là je
peux vous dire qu'on a une une arme eux
ils ont l'arme des migrants mais nous on
a l'arme du libre échange bon alors on
surtaxe de 200 % les produits Turcs ça
va pas durer 15 jours l'économ en
attendant pour pour rés le problème
c'est pas ça pardonnez-moi le problème
c'est pas de savoir ce qu'on doit C
inertie cet énorme navireme attendez le
problème c'est pas de savoir parce que
souvent on me pose des questions est-ce
que vous feriez bien et tout et cetera
le problème c'est pas de savoir ce qu'on
doit faire on sait bien sûr on n pas les
détails parfaits mais on n pas au
pouvoir le problème c'est comment on
prend le pouvoir à une classe
d'incapable et de corrompu vous pesez
vos mots oui je le pense je dis ce que
je pense vous m'invitez je dis ce que je
pense j'espère c'est
touton Macron il est
corrompu Vals il est corrompu je leur
laisse le choix benoî il est corrompu je
vous laisse le choix d'accord le
bénéfice du doute c'est ça écoutez soit
ils sont incapables soit ils sont
corrompus d'accord non mais j'ai peur
c'est tellement évident d'ailleurs je
crois que on les surestime souvent
suffit d' le serrer la main on les
surestime donc pour pendant quand je
jeux attendez je veux finir un point
là-dessus non mais vous me dites qu'on a
du temps ou ou non mais c'est vous he il
y a pas de problème non mais c'est
important oui parce que si on comprend
pas les personnes si on comprend pas les
personnes et le jeu la manière dont ça
se passe je pense qu'on n pas la bonne
thérapie
euh en
fait souvent je pense que c'est on voit
des complots de la corruption partout
non il y en a certains qui tirent leurs
épingles du jeu mais eux sont pris dans
un espèce de tourbillon d'événements
avec le problème de la dictature
médiatique avec le problème des des
intérêts tout basique avec le problème
de la course au suffrage avec le
problème du manque de culture
historique c'est-à-dire qu'il y a pas un
responsable il y a pas un voyez il y a
une espèce d'enchaînement néfaste et
c'est ça qui est terrible et et moi ma
ma plus grave interrogation quand j'ai
des moments de doute parce que je suis
un être humain comme les autres c'est de
me dire comment dans un système
médiatique de l'événemen cel du zaapigne
du spectacle et c'est pas que la faute
des journalistes il y a des journalistes
très bien contrairement à ce qu'on dit
comment dans cette espèce de non mais il
y en a il y a des gens je peux vous dire
j'en connais qui sont comment vous
faites pour vous
informer comment je fais pour m'informer
je m'informe je suis très
curieux je crois que c'est ma
force en tout cas ça explique ma volte
c'est que je suis très curieux de tout
je m'informe beaucoup j'étais longtemps
très papivore c'està dire j'aimais
beaucoup lire de tout dans les journaux
partout des petites parfois des petites
nouvelles internet est une mine et
surtout j'ai un réseau
d'informateur très particulier je crois
que je suis un des seuls hommes
politiques à ce point à avoir sur mon
mes mails des trucs très bizarre de
partout quand je dis très bizarre ça
peut être une madame Michu qui est
au des policiers qui m'envoient des
trucs marrants des des gens très
différents des chefs d'entreprise des
responsables associatifs j'aime bien
l'information éclectique même mes
collaborateurs se plaignent en disant
que je suis que je perd du temps à
m'informer trop différemment mais moi je
pense que c'est une richesse de pas être
prisonnier c'est ma terreur de pas être
prisonnier d'une seule source
d'information de son propre milieu
social de son propre ça a été le secret
de ma réussite dans ma ville je
crois dans ma viille ça surprend
toujours c'est que je suis extrêmement
bien informé de tout par des gens
différents ça peut être le le concierge
du coin d'une résidence qui a un rapport
direct avec moi ça peut être le gardien
d'un stade ça peut être et c'est des
liens humains sympa et ils m'ont sauvé
des dizaines de fois la petite
information qui vous dit attention
monsieur le Maire là vous déconnez vous
service déconne ou j'ai entendu ça voyez
cette espèce d'ouverture ça je pense
c'est très important et les milieux
sociaux français sont trop canalisés
cloisonnés le problème de la France
c'est cette absence de c'est marrant il
parle tout le temps de diversité et
d'identité de respect des identités
machin et tout il y a pas plus homogène
centralisé fermé à l'évolution du monde
on va on va continuer sur la
géopolitique l'Arabie Saoudite la
Turquie la Syrie l'Égypte la Russie les
États-Unis je vous ai
écoute précisez votre question les la
schizophrénie diplomatique française
avec l'Arabie saoudite le Qatar commence
par ça ou voulez plus simple non mais
allez-y moi je réponds au question
comment vous expliquez qu'on vend des
armes à l'Arabie
Saoudite on doit gagner de l'argent y
compris des laboratoires
P4 on a vendu un laboratoire P4 à
l'Arabie Saoudite oui je ne savais pas
mais il faut demander à votre
gardien non mais ce qui est clair c'est
que notre diplomatie euh a perdu son a
perdu le nord c'est-à-dire c'est elle a
perdu le nord parce que elle est
opportuniste pour sauver de l'emploi en
France et faire revenir des devises ou
elle a perdu le nord parce que elle est
dirigée par des
gens aveugles les deux
elle a perdu le nord aussi parce que je
pense que on est dans le courttermisme
on n pas eu N il y a pas d'analyse euh
qu'est-ce qu'une politique
étrangère vous savez j'ai j'ai beaucoup
discuté avec l'ancien conseiller du
général de Gaulle pierre Maillard pierre
Maillard est venu me soutenir pendant la
campagne présidentielle de 2012 très
émouvant il a été le conseiller
diplomatique du général de gaaule très
âgé mais conseiller diplomatique et il
me disait toujours mon petit Nicolas une
politique étrangère est d'abord au
service de l'intérêt national et une
politique étrangère n'est qu'un bras
c'est une pensée stratégique quelle est
la pensée stratégique de la France quel
rôle elle veut avoir qu'est-ce qu'elle
défend comment hiérarchie ça après c'est
la conséquence mais là on a tout inversé
on a des politiques par pays en fonction
des clientèles des ventes des chefs
d'entreprise des corruptions peut-être
des copinages des sympathies c'est pas
ça une politique étrangère ce qui fait
que la politique étrangère elle navigue
comme un bouchon sur l'eau et avec des
contradictions absolument prodigieuse
majeur bah les contdictions entre des
liens trop étroits et nos intérêts
évidents voilà la Russie sur la Russie
c'est très simple moi on m'accuse d'être
proorusse absurde je suis ami de la
Russie parce que je pense que c'est un
grand peuple comme on pourrait être ami
des Américains parce que c'est aussi un
grand peuple
mais on
doit à tout moment se dire je j'ai la
politique de intérêts point j'estime
qu'aujourd'hui il y a plus de danger
venant d'un fanatisme islamiste au
Moyen-Orient que de la Russie comme je
dis toujours à certains journalistes qui
me posent des questions indignées sur la
Syrie je leur dis jusqu'à présent c'est
pas Assad ni Poutine qui ont tué les
gens au Bataclan et à Nice bon donc
revenez me voir plus tard quand ça sera
le cas je veux dire c'est for de
provocation mais il y a un moment ça
suffit quoi donc moi ce que je vois
c'est les intérêts du pays aujourd'hui
on a des on a des intérêts convergents
et pas divergents comment on fait pour
arrêter le terrorisme oh là là c'est il
y a tellement de strates de causes
différentes allez on s'en fait
trois c'est déjà réducteur
euh premièrement d'abord euh on améliore
notre information si on avait pas fermer
notre ambassade en en Syrie on serait
peut-être pas là russi hein euh donc
donc être mieux informé mais je suis pas
assez bon et je suis pas au pouvoir pour
vous dire les secrets des
renseignements deuxè point on a une
politique étrangère plus cohérente et ce
qu'on a fait en Syrie est un exemple
même de tout ce qu'il faut pas faire je
pense ça restera dans les écoles
d'histoire comme
le ratage diplomatique et militaire le
plus intégral et puis
troisièmement on luttera pas contre le
terrorisme si on ne reconsidère pas la
mondialisation inhumaine mercantile
inégalitaire qui est en train d'emporter
le
monde parce que le terrorisme c'est une
forme aussi de désespoir de violence qui
a des causes ça ne veut pas dire
j'excuse le terrorisme qu'on soit clair
mais on peut essayer de comprendre les
causes des Teros c'est-à-dire une
société c'est souvent Dieu sait si je
combat le fondamentalisme islamique mais
c'est pas avec le consumérisme
occidental suffisant qu'on et la
pauvreté de masse qu'on arrivera à
éradiquer le voilà il faut quand même
réfléchir un peu plus loin une troisème
non bah ça fait trois déjà d'accord
après on peut en avoir plein d'autres
militair ce qui est extraordinaire c'est
là où la vie politique est incroyable
c'est il y a une mémoire courte mais ça
c'est le problème médiatique les médias
ne ne mettre plus en perspective les
choses donc quand vous pensez que c'est
quand même Nicolas Sarkozi François
Fillon qui on supprimé 45000 po de
militaire et qui maintenant nous font
des grands discours sur le réarmement de
la France et que Hollande avait continué
70000 postes de militaire supprimé en 7
ans je me souviens d'une d'une séance
surréaliste en commission de fa défense
nationale dans les années sous Sarkozi
début il y avait les nénarable Morin
ministre de la Défense et qui venait
nous expliquer qu'il fallait plus de
base en Afrique et qu' faisait Abu Dhabi
et l'Afghanistan et cetera Djibouti non
et comment Djibouti il avait dit euh non
c'était le Sénégal qui voulait fermer
puis Jamen je sais plus où bref et
j'étais intervenu en disant enfin
attendez quand on connaît le
développement de l'Afrique qui va
arriver quand on voit les richesses qu'
y a en Afrique quand on voit l'affaire
de la Chine en Afrique quand on voit
tout ça dire qu'il faut plus de base en
Afrique et qu'il faut tout mettre Abu
Dhabi et en Afghanistan enfin il y a pas
besoin d'être un grand géopoliticien
pour dire que c'est débile bah voilà et
tout le monde est enthousiaste et
applaudissait le père Morin 2 ans après
on a dit ah bah c'est une
connerie voilà court terme court terme
absence de vision absence de recul mais
je dis pas que j'ai raison surtout je
suis pas parfait mais il y a un minimum
quand même la
dette la dette il faut emprunter
directement auprès de la Banque de
France à 0 % comme l' fa le général de
Gaulle par le principe des avances
remboursables et nous aurions 1/3 de
dett c'està dire qu'au lieu d'être à
2000 milliards nous serions à
600 voilà alors la la dette qu'on a
contracté là les 2200 milliards qu'on a
contracté et ben je propose une mesure
très simple je propose euh de rembourser
parce que je ne veux pas rentrer dans un
système de défaut organisé mais je suis
plus subtile je vais prendre les mêmes
armes je
réemprunterai à 0 % auprès de la banque
centrale pour rembourser euh la dette à
intérêt et je le ferai je l'avais déjà
proposé en 2012 c'était l'un j'étais
l'un des seuls à l'avoir conceptualisé
avec un programme de 100 milliards par
an et on divisait on réduisait les
intérêts de les charges d'intérêt du
budget de 17 milliards au bout de 5 ans
j'ai refait le calcul si là on parce que
je j'actualise mon programme c'est
normal pas prendre faut être précis j'ai
calculé avec comme les taux d'intérêt
ont baissé comme les taux d'intérêt à
baisser si on gérait le si on empruntait
le déficit budgétaire français à 0 %
auprès de la banque centrale on
économise à peu près 2 milliards
d'intérêts par an cumulés c'est-à-dire
qu'en 5 ans on économise 8 à 10
milliards c'est curieux tous ces gens
qui veulent économiser sur les policiers
sur les militaires sur les infirmières
pensent jamais économiser sur les
intérêts
d'emprunt à votre avis pourquoi bah vous
le savez c'est moi qui devrais vous
renvoyer la
question c'est un des un des points
majeurs majeur l'escroquerie de la dette
mais j'étais un des premiers à le
soulever et je continuerai àassablement
donc on la répudie pas je ne la répudie
pas je l'absorbe en faisant du judo
oui
l'Europe on reste dedans on sort on en
fait quoi on la transforme de fond en
comble ou on s'en va tout seul avec vos
petits bras oui parce que la France
c'est pas des petits bras la France
c'est la France c'est un pays qui a 1000
ans d'histoire plus même c'est un pays
qui est la France et c'est un pays qui
en tout cas moi à l'Élysée ne se
laissera plus marcher dessus et donc si
ça si vous arrivez pas à ré une merde
bah j'espère bien quand même si vous
donc la France elle se fait respecter et
donc si vous arvez et quand la France se
lèvera et dira to cette construction
dictatoriale qui a défiguré l'idée
européenne seffondrera comme un Chotteau
de carte parce que le jour où la France
fera ça vous en faites pas l'Italie et
les autres le feront je n'ai aucun souci
là-dessus c'est toujours ce défétisme
Français cette espèce de manque de
confiance en soi d'une nation qui est
une grande nation qui va céder face mais
vous faites ça ça tombe c'est un château
de carte qui ne tient que par la
aboration j'emploie ce mot à dessin des
élites des différents pays donc est-ce
que vous avez envisagé une dislocation
de l'Europe j'ai envisagé mieux parce
que je ne me réjouis pas l'enjeu c'est
pas de détruire l'enjeu c'est de
reconstruire et je suis le seul avoir
publié un traité alternatif que vous
trouvez sur mon site internet pour une
Europe des projets et des nations libres
plus exactement des nations libres et
des projets de coopération
variable c'est-à-dire c'est très simple
nous récupérons nos lois nos frontières
nos budget notre monnaie nous vivons
nous assumons nos responsabilité nous
avons un seul ordre juridique national
une démocratie et cette démocratie
coopère avec les autres démocraties sur
la base de coopération à la carte sur
des enjeux où nous ne sommes pas assez
forts pour travailler seul et on le fait
à trois ou quatre pays ce qu'on a fait
avec abus euh on était largué par
américains on avait reconstitué une
industrie une industrie
aéronautique et bien on a pu rattraper
le retard ça a mis 30 ans 40 ans on l'a
fait on avait le nucléaire général de
gale a reconstruit une industrie
nucléaire au début il l'avait pas ça
s'est fait à la force du poignet et
qu'on ne me dise pas que la France à la
fin de la guerre était la 5è puissance
mondiale on est un pays en ruine et on
l'a fait il y aura pas de fuite de
capitaux ou d'évasion fiscale avec ce
projet là il y aura pas de fuite de
capitaux mesur fiscal parce que il y
aura si ce sont des gens déraisonnables
qui font ça c'est quoi des gens
déraisonnables ce sont des gens qui
pensent que en sortant de l'Europe on va
raser gratis et qu'on pourra dire au
français votre SMIC est à 3000 € la
retraite est à 60 et bonnes gens dormez
tout va bien non moi j'ai jamais dit ça
moi ce que je dis c'est français vous
voulezêtes un peuple libre vous voulez
que vos enfants vivent bien il va
falloir faire des efforts collectifs
mais ils seront partagés et on va s'en
sortir ensemble donc moi je propose une
sortie de crise qui passe par une
libération de l'Europe mais qui passe
aussi par des efforts
nationaux et si les anti-européens ou
les eurosceptiques c'est pas
anti-uropéens parce que je tombe dans le
piègeadversaire les anti-union
européennees vous vous êtes proche de N
Farage oui j'aime beaucoup Farage mais
Farage est anglais moi je suis français
le frxit le brexit correspondait
parfaitement à l'âme anglaise je ne
pense pas que les Français élisent un
président qui veilleent le frexit
aujourd'hui je pense en revanche que les
Français ont très bien compris le piège
européen et moi ce que je propose c'est
un contrat au français et je leur dis
c'est très
simple j'ai un projet comme le général
de Gaulle vis-àvis de l'OTAN il avait un
projet alternatif il a été voir les
Américains les autres ils ont refusé ce
projet il est sorti du comm militaire
intégré moi j'ai un projet alternatif je
vais voir les autres soit il l'acceptent
et je pense qu'ils l'accepteront
beaucoup plus parce que le système sinon
est mort et on le met en place soit il
ne l'accepte pas et on s'en va mais
c'est pas le frexit pour le frexit c'est
reconstruire reconstruire une Europe des
nations et des
projets le pose ta question c'était quoi
ta question C on parle de contrat le
contrat quel pouvoir au
peuple le pouvoir de maîtriser son
destin alors une fois qu'on a dit ça ça
veut dire quoi ça veut tout dire et rien
dire exactement merci
oui enfin c'est déjà pas mal de quoi de
rien dire non de tout dire c'est-à-dire
que le droit des peuples à disposer de
même il serait peut-être temps qu'on
s'en souviennent aussi bon il est
valable pour tous les peuples de la
terre sauf pour le peuple français bon
donc ça veut quand même dire quelque
chose après la question que vous posez à
travers votre marque desésobligeante
toujours com c'est de fabrique comment
mais ça me m'ébranle pas comment c'est
par un ensemble de règles c'est le
référendum c'est le référendum
initiative populaire c'est la
connaissance du vote blanc c'est un peu
de proportionnel à l'Assemblée pour
aérer tout ça c'est la refondte du
système médiatique avec la création de
fondation où les Français seraient
propriétaires de leurs médias et
certaines règles pour limiter le conflit
d'intérêt euh bref c'est un ensemble de
choses c'est bien évidemment à cause de
tout de reprendre le pouvoir à l'Union
européenne parce que ça sert à rien de
parler de de démocratie en France s'il y
a plus de démocratie et que tout est à
Bruxelles dans votre dans votre
programme vous évoquez le salaire
universel ou pas non je travaille en ce
moment et je le sortirai bientôt donc
vous avez un scoop mais je veux pas trop
vous en dire parce que je pas comprenne
mon idée sur l'emploi universel ce
qui'est pas la même chose l'emploi
universel comme en extionon soviétique
oui ben c'est beaucoup mieux que le
salaire universel
ok al ça va se matérialiser en quoi bah
c'est qu'il y a un travail vous allez
faire travailler les gens et ben moi je
préfère faire travailler les gens que de
leur donner un revenu sans travailler
excusez-moi je trouve le débat sur le
revenu universel ahurissant pourquoi
parce que l'enjeu c'est pas de donner de
l'argent c'est d'apprendre à pêcher
ou oui bah oui c'est pas c'est idiot il
avait tout inventé he il avait tout oua
avantous hein donc ils étaient que 12
donc non on parle pas du même alors donc
si vous voulez apprendre à quelqu'un à
manger ou vous lui donnez pas un poisson
à pêcher mais c'est un
évangile bon donc l'écologie on non
attendez 2 secondes oh là je vous en
prie moi c'est vous qui êtes arrivé avec
une heure de retard donc moi il y a pas
de problème vous voulez he je reviens je
vous ai
prévenu juste je reviens à à la question
revenez à la question précédente on est
passé à l'écologie mais le salaire
universel oui non mais c'est très
important bah oui c'est pour ça que vous
l'avez oublé
par dans notre
société l'homme se réalise par le
travail ce travail il ne veut pas dire
obligatoirement
marchant il ne veut pas dire
obligatoirement sous la même forme mais
en revanche donner bonne conscience en
donnant de l'argent toujours insuffisant
sauf à être injuste envers ceux qui
travaillent euh je pense pas que ce soit
la solution donc le revenu universel le
salaire universel si c'est simplement un
moyen pour les grandes entreprises de ne
plus payer leur salariés pour que l'État
le fasse à leur place euh je vois pas
l'intérêt et en plus c'est
déresponsabilisant en revanche l'idée
que dans une période de forte
automatisation de grand gain de
productivité parce qu'on a encore rien
vu et c'est normal faut se projeter dans
la science le monde va évoluer on n'est
pas en temps zéro moi je dis toujours la
vie c'est pas un des photographies c'est
un film il y a une dynamique qui se crée
euh quand on voit ce qui va nous tomber
dessus avec la robotisation avec le
numérique avec la médecine préventive
euh on a absolument besoin d'une
réflexion qui ne se limite pas à dire
bah il y a tant de millions gens qui
rien donc on leur donne une allocation
mais en revanche est-ce qu'il y a pas
des moyens de remettre au travail toutes
ces gens qui ne sont plus dans un
travail marchant
immédiat en tout cas ce qui est clair
c'est que moi je veux qu'à chaque
allocation il y ait une contrepartie
d'intérêt général et de travail comment
vous allez le mesurer c'est vous qui
allez formuler le mais c'est déjà le cas
c'est lequel ne vous trompez pas c'est
déjà le cas c'est déjà le cas d'une
certaine mesure la fonction publique
dans certains cas c'est le cas sans
critiquer du tout les fonctionnaires qui
travaille bien non mais je dis pas
méchantment non non euh sans critiquer
du tout les grande majorité des
fonctionnaires qui travaillent bien mais
on sait très bien qu'il y a une forme
d'ajustement euh les emplois aidés c'est
quoi euh simplement on on a une vieille
mentalité c'est curieux d'ailleurs on a
une vieille mentalité judéo-chrétienne
qui est interdit de se poser la question
de l'emploi universel et qui en même
temps se permet de poser la question
d'apporter la réponse du revenu
universel sans travailler ben moi je
pense que j'ai trouvé la solution et en
tout cas on y réfléchit on présentera
pour la présidentielle dans quelques
semaines un projet très original
l'écologie c'est pour moi un vrai défi
j'ai toujours été
stupéfait que l'écologie soit capturé
par
des
libertaire parce que la protection de la
planète la défense de la nature
euh le respect des
cycles devrait pas être une valeur par
des des des cultivateurs de cannabis
quoi quoi et devrait pas être monopolisé
par eux quoi dans ce que je veux dire
c'est que les vers les verrs sont des
cultivateurs de cannabis ouais les
verres dans l'ensemble c'est c'est quoi
ce raccourci là bah j'ai le droit d'AV
vous avez déjà vous avez déjà fumé du
cannabis non vous ouvriez sans déconner
hein j' aurais dû ça vous ouvrir les
chakras mais en tout cas moi je vous dis
que l'écologie politique à la française
ces ver gauchisant gauchisant et
libertaire ne ont fait beaucoup de tort
on fait beaucoup de tort au vous allez
faire quoi à l'environnement vous gardez
le nucléaire vous gardez pas le
nucléaire alors plusieurs
choses d'abord je pense que sur
l'environnement faut sortir du gadget et
passer à la
masse le coût
marginal de certaines opérations est
délirant je prendre un exemple on
invente des normes absolument délirantes
pour les bâtiments public très coûteuse
pour les nouveaux bâtiments et en même
temps on n'est pas foutu de mettre en
place des incitations financières qui
serait très peu coûteuse mais avec un
gain marginal colossal pour isoler les
millions de logements des Français
moyens qui si pouvait avoir un prêt zé
sur 3000 € un microfinancement ça ça
fait économiser trois centrales
nucléaires ok exact oui mais attendez
vous rigolez vous je rigole pas c'est
fondamental fondamental je veux qu'on
change de braquet et qu'on arrête le
gadget la gadgtisation bobo de
l'écologie pour venir sur une grande
échelle donc vous Prz
deux mesures un bonus malus pour les 20
millions de véhicules à fout à la la
ferraille qui pollue trop et une
incitation à prê au zéro et de
microofinancement
participatif facilité pour tout ce qui
permettrait de réduire la facture
énergétique des Français c'est colossal
et ça ça vaut mieux que de mettre de
l'herbe sur les abribus parisiens quoi
de l'herbe sur les abrius vous pas V la
dernière innovation deamidalgo mais de
l'herbe qui se fume ou bah les deux
peut-être d'ailleurs c'est je connais
pas je fume pas mais c'est peut-être
faut peut-être grimper à l'abribus pour
couper l'herbe vous avez pas vu ça non
vous verrez les nouveaux abribus il y a
de l'herbe qui pousse sur le haut c'est
écologique c'est la l'écologie d'accord
le nucléaire sur le
nucléaire je pense qu'on ne peut pas se
passer du nucléaire aujourd'hui mais je
voudrais qu'on passe à la génération au
torium on est en train alors si si vous
me permettez de vous ouvrir une
parenthèse parce que c'est un sujet
relativement complexe qu'on maîtrise oui
donc le torium vous avez vu donc le le
le documentaire de la famille Robert qui
est passé sur haré non on vous le
conseille fortement revenons un petit
peu sur nos notre cinquantaine de
réacteurs nucléaires vous en faites quoi
mais je les garde mes
pour l'instant je les garde mais combien
de temps et je prépare la suite non mais
vous les gardez combien de temps vous
savez qu'ils étaient prévus pour une
certaine durée qu'ils ont été allongés
que certains parlent de 20 ans en plus
je ne suis pas un expert là-dessus il
faudra voir en temps utile ce qui est
sûr c'est qu'il faut prévoir le
renouvellement il faut prévoir le
renouvellement d'accord et moi je vous
demande est-ce que vous avez anticipé et
modélisé la déconstruction des réacteurs
nucléair oh euh je sais que c'est un
rude défi à combien ça coûte par
réacteur oh vous le savez sans doute
plus que moi faudra demander à
bernardamber donc nucléaire vous avez
pas plus creusé que ça mais si on a
creusé ENF ne me demandez pas de faire
ce que personne ne ne peut faire
c'est-à-dire personne ne peut faire on
se retrouve avec 54 réacteurs nucléaires
indécommissionnaable c'est ça mais euh
il faut l'anticiper et il faut surtout
prévoir la nouvelle génération il faut
peut-être possi provisionner mais bien
évidemment on en est où avec ça c'est un
vrai défi qui se chiffre à combien de
milliards je peux pas vous le dire vous
le savez donc dites-moi la réponse au
lieu de me poser la questions c'est je
vais pas vous dire la réponse je suis
pas là pour c'est environ 1000 milliards
par
réacteur au minimum j'avais pas ces
chiffres bah il faut vous
renseigner donc le torium expliquez un
petit peu nos auditeurs le torium en
tout cas je pense que c'est par la
recherche qu'on arrive s'en sortir et
que il faut pas une écologie comment
dire immobile et castratrice mais il
faut inventer les énergies de demain
quel sera le panneau solaire de demain à
haut rendement énergétique c'est la le
point clé et d'investir massivement
là-dessus deuxième point nous sommes en
train de travailler je vous en dirai
plus dans quelques semaines sur
l'affaire du torium qui me paraît
intéressante mais on m'explique qu'il
faut en même temps 30 ans pour passer à
une phase de la phase expérientale une
phase c'est l'Inde ou la Chine qui
d'ailleurs a commencé à travailler
dessus la
Chine donc bref en tout cas ce que je
sais c'est qu'il faut que notre pays
retrouve une vision stratégique et des
investissements à long terme qu'est-ce
qui pollue le plus selon
vous est-ce que c'est les gaz
d'échappement l'activité industrielle ou
l'élevage on nous dit que c'est
l'élevage d'après ce que j'ai entendu
mais ça peut être le reste j'en sais
rien qu'est-ce que vous pensez des des
conditions
des fermes au mil000 vaches ou 5 je suis
hostile à la ferme au mil000 vaches mais
il suffit pas de dire j'y suis hostile
j'étaé la visiter pour me rendre compte
vous êtes végétarien non vous comptez
l'être non est-ce que vous comptez
donner l'exemple mais j'ai pas donné
l'exemple je je je ne veux pas qu'on
passe un excès à l'autre donc on
nemmerde pas les gens s'ils ont envie de
manger de la viande on a encore le droit
de manger de la viande en revanche on
peut manger équilibré et chacun mange
qu' veut on n'est pas en
dictature voilà non mais mais on va pas
tomber dans le en revanche je suis
hostile au ferm des mille vaches
pourquoi parce que ça déstabilise
totalement notre élevage et nous avons
un pays d'élevage nous avons des
territoires je suis pour une politique
agricole renationalisée si nous n'avons
pas d'accord à Bruxelles ou alors on
recrée une politique agricole commune
réelle et je suis pour des quotas je
suis pour des quotas laitiers je suis
pour des prix garantis je suis pour
qu'on défende une agriculture humaine
qui participe à l'écosystème je suis
aussi pour qu'on réduise fortement les
intrants de toutes sortes qu'on met dans
la terre et qui sont une des principaux
problèmes aujourd'hui écologique qui est
un vrai défi le lien entre la santé et
l'environnement et d'ailleurs dans mon
programme l'écologie est principalement
lié à la santé publique et à
l'alimentation donc mais bien sûr c'est
le problème clé mais si j'avais toutes
les solutions je serais un sûrom je donc
vous avez formé une équipe béton autour
de vous pour vous conseiller mais il
faut
vous êtes combien vous êtes combien dans
votre équipe ça dépend ce que vous
appelez mon équipe à debout la France il
y a 15000 adhérents ce qui est déjà pas
mal 15000 r adhérents il paye combien
pour être adhérant chez vous 10 €
d'accord et combien vous gagnez qui vous
moi ou à titre personnel ouai et ben le
prix d'un député 5000 € 5100 € net c'est
ça voilà plus 5 fonction de de maire qui
est plafonné en fonction de la fonction
de député donc je dois être à
je suis un peu moins de 5000 parce que
je vois sur ma fiche et 4006 al je sais
pas pourquoi ce qu' garde et je dois
avoir un petit emprunt je sais pas ce
qu'il y a une petite cotisation je crois
que j'ai pris le maximum en assurance
vie enfin pasive décès voyez si je me
fais écraser et et je dois toucher 1700
ou
1800 en tant que maire écrité c'est un
cumule des mandat ça oui j'ai un cumule
des mandats mais vous savez
contrairement à ce que les gens croient
il y a pas de cumu total des
rémunérations d'accord je n'ai aucune
autre revenu vous êtes à jour dans votre
déclaration fiscale de patrimoine
j'espère cher
Monsieur on je vais vous dire la chance
que j'ai c'est que depuis que j'ai
quitté
l'UMP et j'ai pris un parcours
indépendant j'étais très surveillé vous
avez eu combien de redressement fiscal
j'ai pas eu de redressements fiscaux
contrôle mais j'ai eu beaucoup de
contrôle combien
oh plusieurs lettres mais qui n'ont
toujours été nickel et et et ma ville
est sans doute la mieux gérée de France
parce que je crois que le contrôle de
l'égalité dans ma ville en nessonne par
les différents préfet a toujours été
fait de manière avec un zel qu'est-ce
que vous pensez du partenariat public-
privé j'y suis totalement esti pourquoi
parce que je n'aime pas le l'économie
mixte je déteste l'économie
mixte parce qu'il y a un mélange des
gens et c'est pas clair et je vais vous
dire c'est beaucoup plus rentable
d'investir euh d'investir et de gérer
soi-même
je crois que la fonction publique peut
être très
performante moi j'ai plusieurs je pense
ENF en tout cas il y a pas d'idéologie
chez moi je vais vous dire par exemple
dans mon agglomération que je gère j'ai
trois piscines j'en ai une en réie et
deux en concession dans les sones il y a
des excusez-moi pardon continuer sur la
piscine oui non mais parce que je vais
vous dire pourquoi je dis ça c'est qu' a
une époque où mes piscines étaient en
régie et les M nageurs se mettaient en
greffe tous les mois de mai avant l'été
ça commenca à suffir et on était pas à
35 he de travail plutôt beaucoup moins
donc à un moment j'ai dit maintenant
faut pas faut arrêter de se [__] de la
gueule du monde je vous aime beaucoup
mais faut se remettre au
travail et on va mettre une nouvelle
piscine en concession et puis on a
négocié le bout de gras et on a compris
et les gens sont intelligents et on
s'est aperçu qu'une piscine bien géré en
régie
fonctionnaire de bons fonctionnaires de
de la ville fonctionnait aussi bien
qu'une piscine en concession mais c'est
parce qu'il y a eu la concession qu' a
eu un électrochoc dans la piscine en
régie et et je pense j'aimerais qu'à
terme les piscines reviennent en régie
peut-être ou en équilibre je pense qu'en
vérité ce sont des faux débats ce qui
est important c'est de jamais de perdre
de vue le service
public le service public et l'idéal pour
moi c'est parfois du statut privé mais
avec un contrôle public ce qu'on fait
les Suédois très bien
d'ailleurs il y a pas de religion
là-dedans a pas de religion làdedans
vous avez aucun dogme rien du tout non
je n'aime pas les dogmes làdedans
revenons un peu sur le cannabis alors
pourquoi pourquoi vous vous modélisez
les les écologistes comme des fumeurs de
cannabis parce que vous voyez très bien
ce que je veux dire non mais si
j'extrapole votre raisonnement ils ont
tous des dreadlock ils ont des chiens et
puis se travalent tout dans la rue oui
un peu c'est un peu ça c'est ça votre
vision de l'écologie non la vision de
certains écolos qui ont décrédibilisé
l'écologie attendez regardez les vers
c'est pathétique attendez yanck jado une
primaire oui oui lui est pas mal
d'ailleurs dans un sens ils ont r vous
pensez que c'est le cannabis qui a
détruit les écologistes c'est leur
culture sont plus libertaires
qu'écologistes voilà l'écologie elle est
partagée dans tous les partis politiques
et tous les Français peuvent être
écologistes sans pour autant
euh être dans un parti vert avec le ses
défauts et ses qualités quand vous voyez
le le Colorado ils sont pas tous comme
ça bien sûr quand vous voyez le Colorado
faut bien rire un peu sinon bah
forcément avec le cannabis c'est plus
facile d'ailleurs quand vous voyez le
Colorado euh légaliser le cannabis avoir
des millions de recettes fiscales en
plus avoir une prévention des risques
liés à la drogue beaucoup plus effectifs
avoir une baisse de la criminalité des
cartels mexicains qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez c'est ce qu'on se dit aujourd'hui
moi j'attends de voir ça fait 2 ans
ouais 2 ans attendez de voir quand
l'Espagne est parti là-dedans on a vu le
résultat l'Espagne le Portugal qui vient
d'ailleurs de de d'enlever toute
criminalisation de consommation stéfi
moi je suis très sceptique je ne veux
pas avoir d'
priori vous savez qu'on est le plus gros
consommateur de canab je le sais je le
sais je ne veux pas d'ailleurs ça fume
beaucoup ah bon c'est une bonne plaque
tournante
d'ailleurs j'attends de voir vous
attendez de voir oui vous êtes pas c'est
une affaire trop grave trop grave
pourquoi le cabis c'est grave oui c'est
une affaire trop grave ce que je veux
dire c'est la santé de nos enfants c'est
une affaire trop grave faut préférez que
vos enfants ils s'approvisionnent dans
les cités dans les sones avec du du
matériel un peu trop puiss non non ça
c'est une démission c'est une démission
d'avance non mais c'est pas une
démission c'est du sophisme c'estàd
c'est est-ce que vous avez vu les
qualités de cannabis qui débarqu en
France non mais attendez moi c'est c'est
lamentable je dis c'est pas l'herbre de
M 68 quand vous étiez étudiant mais
j'étais pas étudiant 68 j'étais enfant
donc ne me vieillissez pas trop euh donc
euh deuxièmement je je refuse cette
espèce de démission comme on n' pas
réussi à maîtriser un phénomène c'est
une démission unehypocrisie et ben il y
a les deux entre l'hypocrisie la
situation actuelle est hypocrite vous
avez raison mais est-ce pour autant
qu'il faut démissionner est-ce qu'il
faut pas plutôt taper les réseaux
s'attaquer au vrais trafiquants au gros
bonnets à ceux qui vivent de ça comment
on le dit en anglais ça c'est le war on
drogs c'est ça ben oui ça jamais marché
bah écoutez le président philippin il a
l'air de s'y mettre là bah vous voulez
faire ça en France je j'aurais du mal
vous aurez du mal pourquoi les Français
vous
empêcheront vous verrez
moi je demande à voir hein en tout cas
le l'acisme judiciaire euh la mansuétude
des autorités publiques à l'égard des
trafiquants de drogue est insupportable
et quand je vois les dégâts de la drogue
sur nos enfants sur les vie des gens euh
j'ai pas envie de rire avec ça et j'ai
pas envie de céder à quel dégâts ça crée
la drogue chez les gens écoutez la
drogue on sait très bien ce que ça crée
ça crée des gens qui perdent leurs
capacités cognitive ça perd des ça crée
des gens qui vont pas bien et on
pourrait dire aussi de l'alcoolisme
d'ailleurs c'est quand même pas la
panassée moi je c'est le tabac c'est pas
la panassée moi je me réjouis pas de ça
voilà et j'estime que quand on est un
chef d'État quand on est un homme
politique on cultive pas le on cultive
pas le déclin la décadence voilà pour
vous cannabis c'est le déclin et la
décadence mais comme l'alcoolisme les
ravages de l'alcoolisme les ravages du
tabac c'est quand même débile d'accepter
cette décomposition est-ce qu'il y a
déjà eu une overdose c'est quand même
mieux de vivre de d'essayer de d'élever
le niveau plutôt que d'être une nation
de fumeur de cannabis vous trouvez que
les fumeurs de cannabis n'élèvent pas le
niveau j'estime qu'on met en danger
notre jeunesse et je pense qu'il y a
d'autres choses à faire voilà je suis
désolé de vous le dire ça paraî
peut-être ringar mais je le pense c'est
pas c'est pas ringard c'est pour moi
c'est une inopérance c'est une
inopérance flagrante c'est vous AZ le
droit de penser ce que vous POS la
question j'ai le droit de penser ce que
je veux et j'estime qu'un responsable
public n'a pas accompagner à favoriser
ce type de pratique c'estàdire que les
pouvoirs publics accompagnent avec
l'alcool et le tabac et c'est normal
mais je ne suis pas favorable non plus
et je pense que il faut beaucoup allez
supprimer l'alcool et le tabac quand
vouserez président ça ne sera pas la
prohibition
rassurez-vous qu'est-ce qu'on va faire
alors non mais il y a des moyens quand
même d'éviter ce qu'on voit bah lesquels
tous les moyens ont déjà été employés le
trafic de drogue on n'arrive pas à
l'endiguer en France c'est mais onarrive
pas l'endiguer parce qu'on a une justice
laxiste on on on on se laisse
complètement on laisse des étrangers
d'ailleurs en situation qui devrait être
expulsé de France immédiatement on a on
a une on a une faiblesse une faiblesse
vis-à-vis des trafiquants mais qui est
incroyable
et qui s'exlique si je peux finir qui
s'explique parce que certains gros
bonnets on doivent avoir des bonnes
complicités politique politique
financière et cetera quand on voit le ce
que rapporte les mafias de la drogue
dans le monde on peut s'interroger bon
j'arriverai pas à vous faire lâcher un
seul mot correct sur le cannabis non non
mais en revanche je reconnais une chose
c'est que le système actuel est
hypocrite donc je ne suis pas dans un
espè de dénis de réalité du tout la
guerre contre la drogue est effective
selon vous non il faut la faire mais il
faut la faire vraiment à la
philipine il faudrait éviter d'aller à
cet excès mais s'il faut le faire il
faut le
faire comment la France peut retrouver
ses sa souveraineté numérique ah bah
c'est très simple et très compliqué à la
fois d'abord faudrait qu'elle le qu'elle
prenne conscience du
danger quand vous voyez palentir venir
au secours des services de renseignement
français çaen fout pourquoi mais parce
que y a il y a plus d'indépendance
nationale Microsoft dans la défense tout
pareil c'est insupportable Jean-Marie
Boel qui fait un rapport sur les
serveurs chinois et qui ne critique pas
les serveurs américains h très
intéressant si nous enfin c'est
dramatique mais ça fait des années que
je le dis des années dans la différence
totale
totale mais vous savez la
liberté c'est la fable du chien et du
loup
hein on vous écoute la fontaine vous
connaissez non mais les auditeurs ils la
connaissent pas bon la fontaine qu's
aillent regarder la FME du chien du loup
voilà un conseil pour les jeunes
générations
ah j'ai plutôt confiance dans les jeunes
générations si elles sont pas trop
embrigadé par la pensée unique parce que
je vais vous dire vous savez que ma code
de popularité c'est qui la pensée unique
oh B la pensé unique vous la connaissez
c'est c bien pensant c'est ce enfin tout
ce qu'on a tout ce que je critique
vous savez où est la code de popularité
la plus forte votre code de popularité
oui la plus forte 6,25 % non ça c'est
pas la code deté ça c'est des votes
d'accord votre vote c'est 15 non ça
c'est en 2012 désolé ça n'a rien à voir
bon alors en 2017 non mais attendez
prenez les résultats des élections vous
savez qu'on a fait autant de voix que
les verts ou que le Front de Gauche au
régional mon père m'a toujours dit de me
jamais me comparer au dernier de la
classe mais c'est pas la question c'est
que vous me comparez à quelque chose qui
n'existe plus votre coque de popularité
la plus forte les popularités voilà la
plus forte c'est les 18 24 ans les 18 24
ans
vous voyez mais dans quelle région dans
toute la France toute la France regardez
le Paris matchifop qui me suit depuis
des années et vous verrez euh tous les
sondages les codes de popularité vous
savez al moi je me fixe pas là-dessus ça
monte ça descend mais enfin c'est
toujours à peu près pareil c'est dans
les 30 % bien au-dessus de la plupart
des hommes politiques al là en ce moment
Mélanchon il va fort hein Mélanchon il
va fort peut-être ce que je vous dis euh
c'est pas ça
ça veut dire attendez que les jeunes euh
il y a les jeunes bobos euh parisiens
enfermés dans leurs ctitude et et qui
est dans la propagande et qui vivent pas
d'ailleurs les difficultés des Français
et puis y a la vraie jeunesse qui je
peux vous dire épouse de plus en plus
mes
idées si vous passez pas le deuxième
tour et qu'il y a un Mélanchon mais
pourquoi attendez je me bats pour être
élu je suis d'accord avec vous c'est
tout à votre honneur d'ailleurs de vous
sortir c'est pas la question du second
tour et du premier je me bats pour être
élu point je fais appel aux Français le
disant je suis le plus crédible pour
réussir la rupture
voilà maintenant allez-y un conseil pour
les jeunes générations être libre libre
dans leur tête comment on prend cette
liberté on la Gère c'est justement ça
qui est dur c'est pas facile d'être
libre mais c'est toujours mieux que
d'être un un esclave ou une carpette ou
une limasse vous êtes sur une chaîne de
cœur vous inquiétez pas on connait ça
est-ce que vous avez des questions à
nous poser j'aimerais vous demander qui
vous êtes mais je le découvrirai petit à
petit on est personne on est personne on
a des comme vous des réseaux partout
sûrement beaucoup plus que moi je sais
pas si c'est moi j'ai des soutiens c'est
des soutiens humbles de Français qui
aiment leur pays mais nous on a ça un
peu près partout et ben alors c'est bien
faisons affaire c'est pas gagné c'est
pas gagné ne suis pas pour légaliser le
cannabis je suis désolé non mais on mite
pas pour la légalisation du cannabis on
se pose simplement la question à qui ça
sert c'estàdire que la guerre contre la
drogue la guerre contre la drogue n'a
jamais marché comprends votre je
comprends votre on voit des milliards
passer sous notre nez je je comprend
votre et on voit surtout une politique
de prévention qui n'est pas là on voit
surtout du des drogues débarquer en
France de plus en plus
forte c'est-à-dire que pour avoir moins
de risque avec les douanes il préfèrent
avoir une substance très concentrée et
on expose des jeunes momes à du cannabis
génétiquement modifié pas l'herbe de vos
parents
M68 ni l'herbe des écologistes à
Woodstock donc nous on se pose la
question est-ce que ça va continuer mais
c'est un vrai débat je vais vous dire ce
qui est drôle c'est que dans cette
affaire enfin drôle c'est que c'est le
plus ancien de mon équipe je suis
entouré plutôt de très jeune on a fait
le pédigrade votre équipe vous inquiétez
pas qui entre et et le plus ancien c'est
Dominique jamaet HM et c'est lui qui
nous a abordé cette question en en
bureau politique en disant Nicolas tu
dois prendre une position différente sur
le cette affaire c'est un problème
majeur surtout si vous êtes élu par les
19 24 ans
euh vous savez les gens votent
heureusement pas sur des question
catégorielle mais pour leur vision du
pays qu'est-ce qu'on veut de notre pays
il y a pas de subordnation de vote en
France
qu'est-ce qu'on veut pour notre pays je
vous repose la question il y a pas
denation de en France est-ce qu'on peut
élever le débat est-ce qu'on peut se
dire est-ce qu'on en prend pour 5 ans
avec les mêmes est-ce qu'on a le
masochisme de voter pour des gens qui
nous font souffrir depuis 20 ans où
est-ce qu'on essae autre chose et si on
veut essayer autre chose qu'on essae de
ce qu'il y a de plus solide sérieux
voilà l'enu donc vous vous êtes solide
et sérieux exactement on beaucoup plus
que les autres Nicolas duponignant merci
merci à
[Musique]
vous